Tyra: AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL IS...
YOANNA.
Yoanna:
AAH! IT'S NOT REAL.
Tyra: THE COMPETITION
MAY BE OVER...
Yoanna: HI. GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
Tyra: BUT FOR
12 AMAZING YOUNG WOMEN,
THE ADVENTURE
IS JUST BEGINNING.
Xiomara:
RIGHT NOW.
WHO'S MAKING MOVES?
WHO'S NOT?
Catie: THE SHOW WAS
COMPLETELY JUST A WARM-UP.
NOW IS, LIKE,
THE REAL COMPETITION.
Tyra: WE'LL FIND OUT
WHO'S HOT...
Man: THAT'S SEXY.
April: I LIKE
THE FEELING THAT I GET
WHEN I'M CREATING ART
WITH MY BODY.
Tyra:
WHO'S HOME...
Shandi:
THANK YOU.
Jenascia:
STILL SLINGIN' CHICKEN WINGS.
Anna: I DON'T REGRET
ANY DECISIONS I MADE.
Tyra:
AND WHAT HAPPENS NEXT.
Shandi: BEING ON THE SHOW
MADE ME REALIZE
THIS IS WHAT I WANNA DO.
Mercedes: THIS IS JUST
THE BEGINNING.
Yoanna:
IT'S INSANE.
IT'S LIKE A DREAM
COME TRUE.
Tyra: ALL THAT COMING UP
ON "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL:
THE RUNWAY AHEAD."
♪♪♪
Tyra: OUR 12 FINALISTS
CAME FROM ALL OVER THE COUNTRY
FROM ALL DIFFERENT TYPES
OF RACIAL BACKGROUNDS,
ETHNIC BACKGROUNDS
AND ALL SHAPES AND SIZES.
AND THEY ALL HAD SOMETHING
IN COMMON--
THEY ALL WANTED TO BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
VOTING A GIRL OFF EVERY WEEK
IS REALLY, REALLY DIFFICULT.
I MEAN, I REALLY BOND
WITH THE GIRLS.
I LEARN ABOUT
THEIR PERSONAL LIFE,
THEIR BOYFRIENDS,
THEIR MOMS,
THEIR INSECURITIES, THEIR FEARS.
THE FINAL VOTE
BETWEEN YOANNA AND MERCEDES
WAS REALLY DIFFICULT.
I MEAN, WE WERE FIGHTING
BACK AND FORTH.
I MEAN, ONE MOMENT, I'M
ACTUALLY PULLING FOR YOANNA,
THEN FIVE MINUTES LATER,
I'M PULLING FOR MERCEDES.
MERCEDES WAS SPUNKY.
YOU KNOW, HER PERSONALITY
WAS SO BUBBLY,
AND SHE JUST HAD
THIS LITTLE "TOUGH GIRL,
BUT I'M SWEET AT
THE SAME TIME,"
AND WE WERE LIKE,
"COME ON, MERCEDES.
COME ON TO NEW YORK."
Mercedes:
MY NAME IS MERCEDES.
I AM 21 YEARS OLD.
I WEIGH 120 POUNDS,
AND I HAVE A LOT OF DREAMS.
I ALWAYS USED TO PUT ON
SHOWS FOR MY MOM
AND SING AND DANCE
IN THE LIVING ROOM.
I WANTED TO BE
AN ASTRONAUT.
I WANTED TO BE THE FIRST
BLACK AND WHITE WOMAN PRESIDENT.
John:
SHE'S A GREAT GIRL.
SHE'S GOT A LOT OF CHARISMA,
A LOT OF CHARISMA,
AND THAT'S IMPORTANT TO ME.
SHE'S GOT
A GREAT WALK, TOO.
Mary:
MERCEDES IS A FUN GIRL.
I MEAN, SHE'S SILLY.
SHE LIKES TO PLAY
WITH HER BROTHER,
AND THEY LOVE TO, YOU KNOW,
HAVE A GOOD TIME TOGETHER.
(playing "Twinkle, Twinkle,
Little Star")
Mercedes: MY MOM IS
ITALIAN-AMERICAN,
AND MY FATHER
IS AFRICAN-AMERICAN,
AND MY STEPFATHER
IS CHINESE.
GROWING UP IN JERSEY,
I WAS THE RUDEST GIRL EVER.
I WOULD GET INTO FIGHTS.
I WAS IN POSSE 6-1.
(siren wailing)
Mary: WE LIVED IN
A TOUGH AREA, ACTUALLY.
Mercedes: YOU HAD TO HAVE,
LIKE, THE BAGGY PANTS,
THE HOOP EARRINGS
WITH THE BANGS.
MOVING TO VALENCIA, CALIFORNIA,
IT WAS A GOOD NEIGHBORHOOD,
AND I THINK THAT CHANGE
INFLUENCED ME
TO JUST BE
A BETTER PERSON.
IT'S BEEN A CRAZY TURN
OF EVENTS.
I WAS DIAGNOSED WITH LUPUS,
WHICH IS A CHRONIC ILLNESS
THAT ATTACKS
YOUR IMMUNE SYSTEM,
AND I DON'T WANT MY
ROOMMATES TO KNOW.
Janice: MERCEDES,
LATELY I'VE NOTICED
YOUR ENERGY HAS GONE
DOWN A LITTLE.
WHAT HAPPENED TO YOU, GIRL?
Mercedes: I DON'T
WANNA MAKE EXCUSES
THAT I HAVE AN ILLNESS,
BUT I DO.
UM, I HAVE LUPUS.
AFTER JANICE REVEALED
TO THE WORLD THAT I HAD LUPUS,
IT WAS BETTER, BECAUSE
PEOPLE WERE SUPPORTIVE.
Tyra: MERCEDES
HAS THAT PERSONALITY
THAT IS A TOP MODEL PERSONALITY,
AND SHE'S FIGHTING A DISEASE.
SHE HAS THESE THINGS
AND THESE EXPERIENCES
THAT YOU LOOK AT THIS
SWEET GIRL, AND YOU GO,
"WOW, I DIDN'T KNOW THAT."
Nigel: SHE REALLY WAS ONE OF
THE BEST GIRLS ON THE RUNWAY,
BUT THE THING IS,
IS DOES SHE HAVE THE FACE
TO SORT OF GRAB
INTERNATIONAL MARKETS,
THE WHOLE OF AMERICA?
Tyra: AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL IS...
YOANNA.
Mercedes: I WAS DISAPPOINTED
WHEN I WAS ELIMINATED
BECAUSE I WAS LOOKING
ALL THE WAY AT THE LIGHT
AT THE END OF THE TUNNEL,
AND I DIDN'T QUITE GET THERE.
IT WAS LIKE TEN SECONDS LEFT
IN A BASKETBALL GAME.
YOU KNOW, THAT LITTLE INCH--
IT SUCKS! IT SUCKS SO HARD!
THE COMPETITION
HAS NOT YET ENDED, FOLKS.
YOANNA, I HEARD, IS IN A SHOW
THIS WEEK FOR FASHION WEEK,
BUT I GOT THE BEST SHOW.
I OPENED UP WITH LLOYD KLEIN,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I'M SUPPOSED TO BE
GOING THAT WAY.
Janice: THIS WAS MERCEDES'
FIRST REAL FASHION SHOW.
Mercedes: SO I JUST FINISHED
THE MERCEDES-BENZ FASHION SHOW,
AND NOW I'M GOING TO AUDITION
FOR THE ENYCE,
WHICH I'M REALLY EXCITED
'CAUSE IT PAYS $500,
AND I HAVEN'T HAD
A PAYCHECK IN SIX MONTHS.
OKAY, MY HOPES AND GOALS--
I WANT TO AT LEAST GRACE
THE COVER ON A "VOGUE."
I WOULD LIKE TO PURSUE
ACTING,
AND I WOULD LIKE
TO HELP PEOPLE WITH LUPUS.
I'M JUST GONNA
KEEP ON GOING.
Tyra: MERCEDES JUST SIGNED
WITH NEW MODEL MANAGEMENT
IN LOS ANGELES.
SHE HAS AN AD COMING OUT
IN "SEVENTEEN" MAGAZINE,
AND SHE'S STARRING IN
AN INDEPENDENT FILM
CALLED "LOVE NEST."
Sara: THIS EXPERIENCE HAS
CHANGED MY LIFE MIRACULOUSLY.
PEOPLE RECOGNIZE ME
ON THE STREET, LIKE,
RUNNING UP TO ME,
FOLLOWING ME IN STORES,
SHOUTING MY NAME OUT.
I AM HALF-PERSIAN,
HALF-AMERICAN.
Mercedes:
WHAT IS THAT?
Sara:
IT'S FROM IRAN.
MOSQUES. IT'S HAND-PAINTED.
I AM SO PROUD OF MY
PERSIAN CULTURE,
BUT TO MY IRANIAN FAMILY,
MY FATHER, WHO'S MUSLIM,
A MODEL IS A WHORE.
Man:
THAT'S SEXY. RIGHT ON.
Sara: MODELING IS NOT
THE JOB FOR A DAUGHTER.
Laura: SARA'S RELATIONSHIP
WITH HER FATHER--
I SEE IT AS--
IT'S UNFORTUNATE.
THEY JUST HAVE NOT COME TO
AN AGREEMENT ON, YOU KNOW,
HOW SHE SHOULD
LIVE HER LIFE.
OH, THESE WILL BE PRETTY.
Sara: MY MOM RAISED ME
FROM WHEN I WAS
JUST A LITTLE BABY
IN SEATTLE.
SAME STORY
A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE--
SINGLE MOM-RAISED,
NOT A LOT OF MONEY.
Laura: I HURT FOR SARA,
QUITE ACTUALLY,
BECAUSE I THINK
SHE MISSED OUT,
YOU KNOW,
NOT HAVING A DAD.
Sara: HE HAS
A DIFFERENT IDEOLOGY
OF WHAT HE WANTS ME TO BE.
I'M VERY PROUD OF
WHAT I AM, BUT AGAIN,
THIS IS THE INDUSTRY
I LOVE.
Laura: SHE ALWAYS SAID,
"I WANNA MOVE TO NEW YORK.
I WANNA BE
A HIGH FASHION MODEL."
THEN SHE BECAME
VERY INTERESTED
IN THE "SPORTS ILLUSTRATED"
SWIMSUIT EDITION.
Sara: I STILL WALK INTO
ROOMS, AND I SEE MODELS
WHO ARE, LIKE, SIZE 0, AND
I'M SITTIN' THERE WITH BOOBS
AND, YOU KNOW,
I HAVE A SHAPE TO ME,
AND I'M JUST LIKE,
OH, MY GOD.
Tyra: I THINK THAT SARA
IS THE ONLY GIRL HERE
THAT HAS THAT
SUPER TOP MODEL LOOK.
SHE CAN STAND RIGHT NEXT
TO ME AND HEIDI
IN A VICTORIA'S SECRET AD--
ALL OF US--AND FIT RIGHT IN.
Eric: SARA, FOR ME,
I THINK JUST IS STARTING--
I'M STARTING TO FEEL THAT
SHOULD COULD BE GOING
WAY DOWN MARKET,
LIKE THE BEER COMMERCIALS.
Tyra: YOANNA,
CONGRATULATIONS.
Sara:
(sobbing)
BEING ELIMINATED
WAS EXTREMELY HARD.
IT REALLY DID HURT
THAT MUCH AND MORE
THAN WHAT YOU SAW
ON THE SHOW.
IT WAS A REALLY
EMOTIONAL EPISODE.
IT REALLY WAS.
TODAY I'M AT
THE "MAXIM" SHOOT.
THEY WANTED TO SHOOT ME,
I GUESS,
BECAUSE OF THE WHOLE
"SEXY" THING ON THE SHOW,
SO I'M DOING MY FIRST
PHOTO SHOOT
HERE AT "MAXIM"
IN NEW YORK CITY.
MY MAIN FOCUS IS MORE
OF THE LINGERIE/SWIMSUIT.
THE OUTFITS ARE BARELY
EVEN CALLED OUTFITS.
THEY'RE LIKE LITTLE
PIECES OF LINGERIE.
I WANNA BE
IN "SPORTS ILLUSTRATED."
PUT ME IN THERE!
NO. (laughs)
IT'S BEEN MY DREAM
SINCE I WAS A LITTLE GIRL.
I WILL ROCK IN IT.
ROCK & REPUBLIC-- IT'S GONNA
BE MY FIRST RUNWAY SHOW
SINCE "TOP MODEL"
STOPPED AIRING,
AND I'M EXCITED.
YOU KNOW, I HAD
TO WALK FOR THEM AND...
I'M JUST-- I'M EXCITED.
I JUST WANNA BE ABLE
TO, YOU KNOW, KICK ASS
AND HAVE PEOPLE
LOOK AT ME
AND BE LIKE,
"OH, WE WANT HER AGAIN."
Audience: (cheering)
Tyra: SARA JUST SNAGGED
A MEETING
WITH THE HEAD OF THE
"SPORTS ILLUSTRATED"
SWIMSUIT EDITION, SO HER DREAM
JUST MAY COME TRUE.
COMING UP: CAN I GET YOUR
AUTOGRAPH?
OF COURSE!
HOMETOWN HEREO'S
WILLMAR'S OWN KATIE ANDERSON.
AND FRIEND'S AND FAMILY
REUNITED.
BRAVO!
ON AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,
THE RUNWAY AHEAD.
THERE IS A BIG DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN BEING A MODEL
AND A TOP MODEL.
A MODEL
IS A GIRL THAT WORKS.
SHE DOES HER CATALOG.
YOU KNOW, SHE MIGHT DO
SOME MAGAZINES
EVERY NOW AND THEN,
BUT THE PUBLIC REALLY
DOESN'T KNOW WHO SHE IS.
THEY DON'T IDENTIFY
WITH HER.
A TOP MODEL
IS A WHOLE PACKAGE.
THERE'S PERSONALITY.
THERE'S LOOKS.
SHE HAS TO KNOW HOW
TO POSE HER BUTT OFF.
SHE HAS TO KNOW
HOW TO DANCE.
SHE HAS TO
KNOW HOW TO SPEAK.
SHE HAS TO KNOW HOW TO
REPRESENT PRODUCTS,
AND SHE HAS TO KNOW HOW
TO RELATE TO THE PUBLIC
WHERE THEY LIKE HER.
THEY WANNA BE HER FRIEND.
♪♪♪
Tim: TIM & TODD,
AND CATIE ANDERSON,
WILLMAR'S OWN
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
I CHECKED OUT UPN,
AND THIS IS THE PICTURE
THEY POST THERE.
I SAID TO TODD,
"NOW I DON'T THINK
SHE'LL BE WEARING THAT
DOWNTOWN."
Catie:
NO, DEFINITELY NOT.
OHH!
Tim: YOU MUST GET RECOGNIZED
EVERYWHERE YOU GO NOW.
Catie: YEAH, IT'S--
OH, MY GOSH.
IT'S WHAT I'VE ALWAYS WANTED.
I WANNA BE A HOUSEHOLD NAME
WHERE PEOPLE--
THEY SEE ME IN A PICTURE,
THEY GO, "OH, MY GOODNESS.
THAT'S CATIE ANDERSON."
Girl: CAN I GET
YOUR AUTOGRAPH?
- Catie: OH, OF COURSE.
- Girl: THANK YOU.
Girl #2: CAN I GET
YOUR AUTOGRAPH?
Girl:
YOU WERE SO GOOD.
Catie:
OH, THANK YOU.
Woman: OH, MY GOSH!
BOYS AND GIRLS, THIS IS
MY FRIEND CATIE ANDERSON,
WHO WAS ON "TOP MODEL."
Mark: AND I REMEMBER CATIE
WHEN SHE LEFT HERE.
SHE TOLD US SHE WAS
GOING TO LOS ANGELES,
AND LO AND BEHOLD,
WE FIND OUT SHE MADE IT
BIG-TIME, SO...
Catie: THIS REALLY ISN'T
MARILYN. IT'S ACTUALLY ME.
YOU KNOW, IF THEY SAID,
"CATIE, TO MAKE IT,
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO SHAVE
YOUR HEAD," MY HAIR'S GONE.
Edward: RIGHT NOW SHE DOESN'T
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S REALLY--
Catie: NO, I DON'T UNDERSTAND
THE WHOLE CONCEPT.
HELP ME.
HELP ME UNDERSTAND.
I HAD EMOTIONAL ATTACHMENT
TO MY HAIR,
SO I KINDA HAD
TO LET IT OUT.
(crying)
I LOOK LIKE A BOY!
I CRIED ABOUT MY HAIR.
I CRIED
BECAUSE OF THE HEIGHTS.
- (rattling)
- Catie: (gasps)
Jay: WE ARE GOING TO SUSPEND
YOU FROM THIS LEDGE
AND SHOOT YOU GUYS
HANGING OVER THIS HOLE.
Catie: I'M SORRY, BUT
ANYBODY WHO HAS A PHOBIA
WOULD UNDERSTAND.
Jay: DO YOU WANNA
COME UP, CATIE?
- Catie: GIVE ME A SECOND.
- Jay: OKAY.
Catie: I'M THINKING, "SUCK IT UP
AND GET IT OVER WITH.
YOU HAVE TO DO THIS.
YOU'RE OUT HERE. YOU
MIGHT AS WELL DO YOUR BEST.
Jay: BEAUTIFUL.
I LOVE IT.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT, CATIE?
WE GOT IT.
YOU'RE DONE.
Catie: I'VE ALWAYS BEEN
VERY OPEN ABOUT MY DREAM.
SINCE I WAS 13,
I'VE WANTED TO MODEL.
MY DAD MEANS
SO MUCH TO ME.
Mary: SHE'S DEFINITELY
DADDY'S LITTLE GIRL.
Ted: SHE'S MATURED A LOT,
YOU KNOW, LIVING ON HER OWN,
AND I THINK THAT
THERE'S A GREAT DEAL
OF PERSONAL GROWTH THAT COMES
ALONG WITH DOING THAT.
Catie: HE'S MY DADDY,
YOU KNOW?
I WANT HIM--I WANT HIM
TO BE HAPPY AND PROUD OF ME.
I HAVE THE BEST FAMILY
IN THE WORLD.
THEY ARE
ABSOLUTELY MY CORE.
Ted: FIRST COUPLE OF EPISODES
WERE FUN TO WATCH.
J.: SHAKE.
SHAKE YOUR BODY.
THIS GIRL CATIE, I THINK,
MAYBE SHE COULD BE A MODEL.
Ted: UM, AFTER THAT,
SOMETIMES THEY GOT
A LITTLE BIT
TOUGHER TO WATCH.
Simon: I THINK THERE'S
A LITTLE TOO MUCH HOOKER STYLE
GOING ON WITH THE LEG WARMERS
WITH THE HIGH HEELS.
Catie: I WAS GOING
DOWNHILL FAST.
I WAS GOING DOWNHILL.
(laughing)
Eric: SHE'S KIND OF
THE GIRL NEXT DOOR.
BUT I THINK
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL
HAS TO BE LIKE THE GIRL,
LIKE, WAY OVER THERE.
Tyra: CATIE, SOMETIMES
THE JUDGES FEEL LIKE YOU ARE
A LITTLE BIT TOO COMMERCIAL,
A LITTLE BIT TOO SAFE.
CAMILLE.
Catie:
I DON'T FEEL REJECTED.
I'M JUST DISAPPOINTED
IN MYSELF.
(crying)
THANKS, GUYS.
I GOT MY ASS KICKED OFF
THE SHOW.
(sighs)
GO BACK TO L.A.,
WORK MY ASS OFF, AND
GET TO THE TOP ON MY OWN.
IT DIDN'T HIT ME UNTIL, LIKE,
TWO WEEKS AFTERWARDS,
AND I'M LIKE,
"OH, I'M NOT ON THE SHOW.
THIS REALLY SUCKS."
WELL, I WOULD LOVE
TO OBVIOUSLY MODEL, ACT...
Man: ACTION.
Catie: AND I WOULD LOVE
TO DO TV HOSTING.
I'M REALLY TRYING TO CAPITALIZE
ON THE MOMENT THAT I HAVE.
'CAUSE I GOT
THIS GREAT EXPOSURE.
NOW IS LIKE THE REAL
COMPETITION.
THAT WAS JUST A WARM-UP.
THE SHOW WAS COMPLETELY
JUST A WARM-UP.
♪♪♪
Anna: YOU KNOW, I LEFT
MY HUSBAND AND MY SON.
Xiomara:
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
YOUR HUSBAND?
HOW OLD IS YOUR SON?
Anna:
HE'S 2.
THE GIRLS WERE SAYING,
"OH, YOU'RE A MOM.
YOU KNOW,
YOU MUST MISS YOUR SON.
YOU MUST MISS
YOUR HUSBAND."
I WAS LIKE,
"YES, I DO MISS THEM."
Makarious:
I miss you, Mama.
Anna:
I LOVE YOU.
Makarious:
I love you.
Anna: I DIDN'T VIEW THAT
AS A HINDRANCE OF ANY TYPE
TOWARD ME OR MY CAREER.
Catie: WHAT DOES YOUR HUSBAND
THINK OF YOU BEING HERE?
Xiomara: MM-HMM.
Anna: OH,
HE SUPPORTS ME 100%.
Jermaine:
EVERYBODY HAVE A DREAM,
AND I KNEW MODELING
WAS HER DREAM.
Anna: IT'S IN ME,
AND I JUST HAVE TO DO IT.
Ed: THIS IS THE MAJOR PART
OF YOUR COSTUME RIGHT HERE.
Anna: I KNEW THAT
THERE MAY BE A CHANCE
THAT I WAS GONNA BE ASKED
TO POSE NUDE.
I WAS HOPING
THERE WOULDN'T BE.
Nigel:
YOU ARE GONNA BE NUDE.
Anna: I SAT THERE IN THE ROOM,
AND I SAW THESE GIRLS.
THEIR COOCHIE WAS SHOWING.
Jermaine: OH, BABY, YOU CAN'T
SAY THAT ON TELEVISION.
Anna: THEIR BREASTS
WERE HANGING OUT
AND NIPPLES SHOWIN'.
I DON'T WANNA BE
A PART OF THAT.
I CAN'T JUST IMAGINE
SOMEONE ELSE HERE
AND DOWN THERE
EXCEPT MY HUSBAND.
Jermaine SHE REALLY
BLEW ME AWAY
BY HER SAYING THEM THINGS
AND STANDING UP
FOR WHAT SHE BELIEVE IN.
Nigel: I'M SORRY, BUT I'M GOING
TO HAVE TO ASK YOU TO LEAVE.
I'M SORRY.
Tyra: THE JUDGES
WERE QUITE DISAPPOINTED
THAT YOU DIDN'T DO
THE PHOTO SHOOT,
BUT YOU FELT
A CERTAIN RESPONSIBILITY
AS A WIFE AND A MOM,
AND WE RESPECT THAT.
THANK YOU, ANNA.
- Anna: THANK YOU, TYRA.
- Xiomara: BYE, MOMMY.
Catie: ANNA--YOU KNOW,
SHE'S IN A DIFFERENT PLACE
IN HER LIFE.
SHE HAS A SON,
AND SHE HAS A HUSBAND.
Makarious: (laughing)
Anna: I DON'T REGRET
ANY DECISIONS I MADE
OR ANYTHING THAT
HAPPENED ON THE SHOW.
I THINK IT WAS A GREAT
EXPERIENCE FOR ME.
GETTING ME OUT THERE--
IT'S EXPOSING ME.
WHEN I DO STEP INTO
MODELING FULL-TIME,
I DO EXPECT TO HAVE MY SON
ON SET WITH ME.
I DO EXPECT
TO HAVE MY HUSBAND.
I WANTED TO BE ABLE TO WORK
BETTER IN THIS BUSINESS
AND WORK ON MY CAREER,
SO I HAVE GOTTEN
DOWN TO A SIZE 6.
I CALLED SOME AGENCIES
AND GOT A CONTRACT.
I'M LOOKING OVER IT,
AND HOPEFULLY I CAN QUIT
MY 9-TO-5 JOB AND START
MODELING FULL-TIME.
I'M ON MY WAY UP.
♪♪♪
Shandi: SHANDI'S LIFE
WILL NEVER BE THE SAME
AFTER "TOP MODEL."
I'M CHANGING EVERYTHING ABOUT
MYSELF BECAUSE OF THE SHOW,
WHICH I AM
VERY GRATEFUL FOR.
IT'S NICE TO WAKE UP
IN THE MORNING
AND THINK
THAT YOU'RE BEAUTIFUL.
MY MOM ALWAYS THOUGHT
THAT I LOOKED LIKE A BOY.
PEOPLE CONSTANTLY TOLD ME,
"YOU'RE NEVER GONNA
GET MARRIED."
I AM FROM
KANSAS CITY, MISSOURI.
I WORK AT A WALGREENS.
I'M A SERVICE CLERK.
IT'S $20.28.
ONE OF THE MAIN REASONS
I WENT DOWN TO THE AUDITION
WAS THE FACT THAT, YOU KNOW,
I HAD NOTHING TO LOSE.
WHEN I FIRST SAW
ALL THE GIRLS...
I THINK ONE OF MY FIRST
THOUGHTS WAS, "OH, OKAY,
I GUESS--
WHAT AM I DOING HERE?
'CAUSE THESE GIRLS ARE
REALLY, REALLY PRETTY."
Bethany: SHANDI--
I DON'T KNOW.
EVEN THOUGH SHE'S
VERY TALL AND THIN,
I JUST DON'T SEE IT.
HER EYES ARE
VERY CLOSE TOGETHER.
SHE KINDA REMINDS ME
OF A BIRD.
Shandi: TO COMPETE
AGAINST THESE OTHER GIRLS,
I'M GONNA NEED
TO DO BETTER.
I NEED TO TRY HARDER.
Eric: THERE'S
A BEAUTIFUL GIRL THERE.
NOT EVERYBODY CAN SEE THAT,
THOUGH.
Tyra: MISS SHANDI
WITH THAT BROWN HAIR,
WE ARE GOING TO MAKE YOU
A PLATINUM BLONDE.
Shandi: EVERYTHING'S
COME TOGETHER.
I FEEL SO PRETTY
RIGHT NOW.
Janice: THIS GIRL IS
A SUPERMODEL IN THE MAKING.
- Shandi: WHOA.
- Eric: WOW!
Shandi: IT STARTED
TO MAKE ME BELIEVE
THAT I BELONGED THERE.
Tyra: ♪ BACK YOUR BAGS ♪
♪ Y'ALL ♪
- ♪ YOU'RE GOING TO MILAN! ♪♪
- Women: (screaming)
Shandi: MILAN, FOR ME,
IS, LIKE, UNBELIEVABLE.
EVERYTHING IS JUST
A MILLION TIMES NICER.
I MISS MY BOYFRIEND.
I REALLY WISH HE COULD HAVE
EXPERIENCED THIS WITH ME.
- Men: CIAO.
- Women: CIAO.
April: YOANNA CALLS
THE REALLY CUTE ONE,
AND HE SAYS HE'LL COME AND
BRING SOME FRIENDS.
- Men: HI.
- Women: HI.
Mercedes: TO LIFE.
Women: AAH! (laughing)
Shandi: JUST CAUGHT UP IN,
LIKE, THE SEXUAL TENSION,
HAVING REALLY
GOOD-LOOKING GUYS COME OVER.
April: DING!
HOLD ON A SECOND, SHANDI.
YOU'VE GOT A BOYFRIEND.
- Eric: Hey.
- Shandi: HI.
- Eric: How are you doin'?
- Shandi: NOT SO GOOD.
THINK OF THE WORST
POSSIBLE THING I COULD DO.
Eric: (shrieking)
You had sex?!
Shandi: YEAH.
Eric: I can't be with someone
that cheated on me.
Shandi: (sobbing)
Shandi: IT WAS ONE
OF THE TIMES OF MY LIFE
WHERE I FELT THE WORST ABOUT
SOMETHING THAT I DID.
I'VE NEVER
FELT SO HORRIBLE.
I JUST HAD NO DESIRE
TO BE THERE,
AND THE JUDGES
COULD SEE THAT, TOO.
Tyra: I WILL ONLY
CALL ONE NAME.
YOANNA.
THANKS, SHANDI.
Shandi: IT WAS HARD
TO EVEN TRY TO REMEMBER
HOW I USED TO BE.
I'VE GROWN MORE IN, LIKE,
THE PAST COUPLE WEEKS
THAN I'VE GROWN, LIKE,
IN THE PAST COUPLE YEARS.
WHEN I GET HOME,
I WON'T FEEL SO LOST.
I WON'T FEEL SO...
INSECURE ABOUT MYSELF.
AFTER THE SHOW, I HAD TO
GO BACK TO WALGREENS.
Woman: OH, WERE YOU
THE ONE THAT WENT--WERE--
- WAS ON THAT MODELING THING?
- Shandi: MM-HMM.
Woman: OH.
Shandi: BUT IT'S JUST
FOR THE TIME BEING.
IT'S NOT A PERMANENT THING.
- Eric: THERE YOU GO.
- Shandi: THANK YOU.
MY BOYFRIEND AND I--
WE'RE STILL HAVING PROBLEMS
WITH THE TRUST ISSUE.
Eric:
WHAT SHE DID WAS WRONG,
BUT I HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO FORGIVE HER.
Shandi:
WE'RE GONNA MAKE IT WORK.
(kisses) I LOVE YOU, MOM.
I THINK THE SHOW
HAD A LOT TO DO WITH, UM,
I DON'T NECESSARILY FEEL
CLOSER TO MY MOM,
BUT I FEEL LIKE A LOT OF, UM,
MY FEELINGS HAVE BEEN RESOLVED,
WHICH HELPS ME WANT
TO BE CLOSER TO MY MOM.
Vivian:
I'M VERY PROUD OF SHANDI.
I NEVER IN MY WILDEST
DREAMS THOUGHT
THIS WOULD EVER HAPPEN
TO ONE OF MY GIRLS.
Shandi:
I'M GOING TO NEW YORK,
AND I'M GONNA MEET
WITH EIGHT AGENCIES.
- Vivian: EIGHT?
- Shandi: EIGHT.
Vivian:
SHE DIDN'T TELL ME EIGHT.
Shandi: ALL THESE
THINGS ARE HAPPENING
LIKE THESE INTERVIEWS
AND GETTING READY
TO DO PHOTO SHOOTS
FOR MAGAZINES.
I'M TRYING TO SAVE UP MONEY
TO MOVE TO NEW YORK
AND GET MY CAREER GOIN'.
BEING ON THE SHOW
MADE ME REALIZE, YOU KNOW,
THIS IS WHAT I WANNA DO.
IT'S GIVEN ME THE DETERMINATION
TO NOT TRY AND WORRY ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT
I'M GONNA MAKE IT,
JUST TO AT LEAST TRY.
Tyra: SHANDI'S SHOOTING
A BIG MAGAZINE SPREAD
IN "GLAMOUR" AND "CosmoGIRL!"
♪♪♪
Bethany:
MY NAME IS BETHANY.
I CAN OBVIOUSLY DO
SWIMSUITS.
THAT'S WHAT SOME PEOPLE WANNA
PUT ME IN THAT CATEGORY--
'CAUSE I'M BLONDE
AND HAVE BIGGER BOOBS,
BUT I HAVE A LOT MORE TALENT
THAN THE BOOBS.
Eric: I'M NOT SO SURE
ABOUT THE BOOBS.
- Tanya: 33 1/2.
- Bethany: HA HA.
Tyra: YOUR BODY TYPE
IS VERY SEXY.
YOU HAVE TO BE VERY
CONSCIOUS OF HOW YOU POSE,
'CAUSE IT'LL TAKE YOU AWAY
FROM FASHION.
Xiomara: BETHANY'S BODY
IS MORE VOLUPTUOUS.
Bethany: WELL, OBVIOUSLY,
I KNOW THAT I DON'T HAVE
A STICK-THIN FIGURE.
I HOPE THAT PEOPLE WOULD
STOP LOOKING AT MY BOOBS
AND START
LOOKING AT SOME TALENT.
I WANT SOMETHING
TO WORK ON.
I CAN'T DO
ANYTHING ABOUT MY CHEST.
Tyra: YES, YOU CAN.
YOU CAN POSE DIFFERENTLY.
YOU'RE NOT THE ONLY MODEL
THAT HAS A BIG CHEST.
YOU'RE HERE BECAUSE
YOU WANNA BE A FASHION MODEL.
Bethany: WHAT CAN I DO?
BUT IT'S JUST--
Tyra: YOU'RE HERE.
SO YOU HAVE TO LEARN
TO WORK IN THIS WORLD.
Bethany: I DEFINITELY
DIDN'T THINK
I WAS GONNA GO
THIS SOON, IF AT ALL.
I KNOW THAT I HAVE
A LOT MORE TALENT
THAN PROBABLY HALF
THESE GIRLS HERE.
IT'S VERY FRUSTRATING
TO ME.
Woman: SO WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE
TO SEE HAPPEN IN YOUR LIFE?
Bethany: WELL, HOPEFULLY,
GET SOME MODELING JOBS.
I'M THINKING ABOUT
MOVIN OUT HERE TO L.A., UM,
PROBABLY IN A MONTH OR TWO
AND REALLY TRYING TO GO AT IT
HARD PURSUING IT,
SO WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
LATER IN THE SHOW YVONNA'S
FIRST DAY AS AMERICA'S NEXT TOP
MODEL.
IT'S INSANE. IT'S LIKE A DREAM
COME TRUE.
AND UP NEXT, APRIL'S FIRST
PROFESSIONAL PHOTOSHOOT.
MONEY. THAT'S IT. RIGHT THERE.
Tyra: A LOT OF TIMES,
PEOPLE WILL WATCH THE SHOW
AND GO, "WHY IS THAT GIRL
ON THERE?
SHE'S NOT
DROP-DEAD GORGEOUS,"
AND IT'S LIKE, THAT'S NOT
WHAT IT TAKES ALL THE TIME.
SOME OF THE TOP MODELS
IN THE WORLD
AREN'T THE MOST
PRETTY GIRLS,
BUT THEY HAVE
AN EXTRA SOMETHING
THAT MAKES THE PUBLIC
CURIOUS ABOUT THAT GIRL.
SO THAT'S WHAT I'M
LOOKING FOR-- JUST SPUNK.
♪♪♪
Jenascia: WHAT'S UP, PEOPLE?
I'M JENASCIA.
I'M BACK IN
SEATTLE, WASHINGTON,
AND I'M ABOUT TO START
MY SHIFT AT HOOTERS!
THAT'S RIGHT,
STILL SLINGIN' CHICKEN WINGS.
SO WHY DON'T YOU FOLLOW ME
IN? LET'S GO.
THIS IS GONNA BE FUN.
COME ON.
ALL RIGHT,
IT'S TIME TO GET SERIOUS.
LADIES, COME PICK UP
YOUR BEER!
DO YOU GUYS NEED ANYTHING?
NO? GOOD.
'CAUSE I DIDN'T WANNA
GET IT ANYWAY.
THERE'S YOUR GUYS'
ENTERTAINMENT FOR THE DAY.
I'M GOING TO BE DOING
MY CROSSWORD PUZZLE.
ENJOY.
I'M JENASCIA.
THE FACT THAT I GOT
CHOSEN FOR THE SHOW
WAS A BIG SHOCK FOR ME.
AND I'M SHORT!
I KNEW THAT I WAS THE SHORTEST
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING
OUT OF ALL THE GIRLS.
AND I WAS THINKIN' THAT,
YOU KNOW, I'LL JUST WEAR HEELS
THE ENTIRE TIME I'M HERE,
BUT... (bleep) IT.
Janice: SHORT.
SHE'S TOO SHORT. LET'S FACE IT.
Eric: 5'7"?
Janice: FOR 5'7",
YOU HAVE TO THINK TALL,
BECAUSE IF YOU THINK TALL,
YOU WILL BE TALL.
SO JUST TRY
A LITTLE BIT HARDER.
Tyra: I LIKE THAT
JENASCIA IS SHORT.
I THINK IT'S SPECIAL.
IT MAKES YOU STAND OUT.
Jenascia:
I'M NOT SHORT!
BUT I ABSOLUTELY REFUSE
TO WALK AROUND IN HEELS
FOR THE REST OF MY LIFE.
Tyra: JENASCIA, YOUR HAIR IS
TOO LONG FOR THAT HEIGHT.
Jenascia: THEY PLAYED
THE TALL CARD WITH ME AGAIN.
THIS SKIRT MAKES MY LEGS
LOOK A LITTLE BIT LONGER,
WHICH IS IMPORTANT.
Tyra: I'M NOT LOOKING AT YOU
HERE TO BE TALLER.
I'M LOOKING AT YOU
HERE TO REPRESENT 5'7".
I'VE GOTTA GET OVER THIS
WHOLE SHORT COMPLEX.
I COULD DRINK ALL THE MILK
WITH CALCIUM IN MY CEREAL,
AND, YOU KNOW,
TAKE SOME VITAMINS ALL I WANT,
BUT I'M NOT GETTING
ANY TALLER.
Janice: LET'S FACE IT.
COUTURE IS TALL, THIN.
Jenascia: HOW THE HELL--
FREAK DO YOU SAY THAT WORD?
HOT COUTURE?
HOTE... HAUTE COUTURE.
BLEHH.
I'VE HEARD A FEW TIMES,
YOU KNOW, "YOU'RE SHORT.
YOU'RE SHORT.
LOOK TALLER."
SCREW IT.
TO BE TOTALLY HONEST WITH YOU,
I JUST WANTED TO ACT,
AND I FELT LIKE MAYBE MODELING
WOULD BE A GOOD STEP INTO IT.
BUT I'M VERY
INTERESTED IN COMEDY.
"SATURDAY NIGHT LIVE,"
CALL ME.
UM... (laughing)
I'M BACK IN THE REAL WORLD,
WHERE I'M TALLER
THAN MOST WOMEN,
AND I CAN STILL
DATE ANY GUY I WANT
BECAUSE I'M SHORTER
THAN MOST OF THEM,
AND THAT... IS A GIFT.
Men: HEY,
JENASCIA SHOULDA WON!
Man: YOU'RE NOT TOO SHORT.
Jenascia:
THANKS, GUYS.
THANKS.
♪♪♪
April: BEFORE THE SHOW,
I WAS WORKING IN MIAMI BEACH
AS AN ACCOUNT EXECUTIVE
FOR AIRBORNE EXPRESS.
WE BOTH MOVED DOWN TO MIAMI,
PATRICK AND I,
AFTER WE GRADUATED
N.Y.U. TOGETHER.
HE'S THE FIRST LOVE
OF MY LIFE.
I WOULDN'T HAVE THE COURAGE
TO DO WHAT I'M DOING RIGHT NOW
IF IT WASN'T FOR HIM.
HE'S REALLY THE ONE
THAT PUSHED ME
TO PURSUE MY DREAM CAREER.
Patrick: ACTUALLY, WE WERE
WATCHING TELEVISION ONE DAY,
FLIPPED THROUGH THE CHANNELS,
SAW THE SHOW.
WE GOT ONLINE,
FOUND THE APPLICATION,
ENCOURAGED HER TO GO AHEAD
AND DO IT.
April: FOR
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
Patrick: I WASN'T SHOCKED
WHEN SHE WAS CHOSEN,
BECAUSE MOST OF THE THINGS
THAT SHE WANTS TO DO IN LIFE
END UP HAPPENING FOR HER.
Martin:
THE WINNER--APRIL!
April: I DON'T THINK I REALLY
KNEW HOW COMPETITIVE I WAS.
Tony: APRIL EXECUTED
THE ROUTINE AMAZINGLY.
Mercedes:
SURPRISE, SURPRISE.
APRIL WON THE CHALLENGE.
SHE'S MOST DEFINITELY
A THREAT.
WHEN SHE SEES SOMETHING,
SHE DOES IT PERFECTLY.
SHE'S LIKE A MACHINE.
Yoanna: MY IMPRESSION
OF APRIL IS THIS.
- Mercedes: (suppresses laugh)
- Yoanna: IT'S THE TRUTH.
April: IT WAS VERY HURTFUL
TO ME WHEN I STARTED TO FEEL
LIKE SOME OF THE GIRLS
DIDN'T SUPPORT ME
OR EVEN SAID
MEAN THINGS ABOUT ME.
Tyra: WE'RE NOT SURE
IF YOU WANT THIS
BECAUSE YOU
WANNA BE A TOP MODEL
AND YOU WANNA BE IN THIS
FASHION INDUSTRY,
OR IS IT THAT YOU JUST WANT
TO WIN FOR THE SAKE OF WINNING?
April: THAT POINT
IN THE SHOW WAS ACTUALLY
THE TURNING POINT FOR ME
WHERE I REALLY STARTED
TO DISCOVER HOW MUCH
I DID REALLY ENJOY
WORKING
IN FRONT OF THE CAMERA.
Nolé: APRIL IS LIKE "CROUCHING
TIGER, HIDDEN DRAGON,"
"THE MATRIX."
SHE WAS FABULOUS.
Janice: APRIL,
YOU'VE GOT THIS NEGATIVITY
TOWARDS YOUR ETHNICITY.
SHE CLEARLY LOOKS ASIAN,
AND SHE SHOULD BE PROUD OF IT.
April: I FELT
SO MISUNDERSTOOD BY THEM.
I CAME ACROSS AS BEING
SOMEWHAT ASHAMED
OF MY JAPANESE HERITAGE,
AND THAT COULD NOT BE
FURTHER FROM THE TRUTH.
Tyra: APRIL, IF YOU MAKE IT,
YOU ARE THE TOP ASIAN GIRL
AT THE MOMENT, OR, CAMILLE,
OR, YOU KNOW, XIOMARA,
YOU GUYS ARE THE TOP BLACK
OR LATIN GIRLS.
April: I'M A MUTT.
I'M A MUTT LOUD AND PROUD,
YOU KNOW?
I'M HALF JAPANESE, GERMAN,
IRISH, SCOTTISH AND WELSH.
I THINK BASICALLY THE JUDGES
MISREAD MY NERVOUSNESS
AS RIGIDNESS,
AND MAYBE MY TIMIDNESS
AS COCKINESS.
Nigel: SHE'S CLINICAL.
SHE'S LIKE A TECHNICIAN.
Stephen:
SHE THINKS TOO MUCH.
SHE'S TRYING
TO DEPICT A MODEL
HOW SHE'S SEEN IT
IN A MOVIE.
Tyra: IN YOUR PICTURES,
WE FEEL LIKE YOU POSE BETTER
THAN ALL THE GIRLS HERE,
BUT MODELING ISN'T ABOUT
BEING MECHANICAL.
IT'S ABOUT EMOTIONALLY
CONNECTING WITH THE CAMERA.
April: (sobbing)
OF COURSE I WAS UPSET
WHEN THEY ELIMINATED ME.
BUT HONESTLY I ONLY CRIED
FOR, LIKE, 30 MINUTES,
AND THEN I GOT OVER IT,
DRIED MY EYES, TURNED AROUND,
WENT BACK HOME AND DECIDED
TO KEEP PURSUING IT ANYWAY.
I'M DOING A PHOTO SHOOT
FOR "STUFF" MAGAZINE TODAY.
I'M REALLY EXCITED.
I WANT TO BE A MODEL
PURELY BECAUSE I LIKE
THE FEELING THAT I GET
WHEN I'M IN FRONT OF A CAMERA,
AND I'M CREATING ART
WITH MY BODY.
IT'S THE MOST AMAZING THING
I'VE EVER FELT.
Man: MONEY.
THAT'S IT RIGHT THERE.
April: IF I COULD
JUST GET THAT FEELING
FOR AS MANY MOMENTS AS I CAN
FOR AS MANY DAYS
OF THE REST OF MY LIFE,
I WILL DO IT.
I WILL WORK HARD
TO BE A MODEL.
Tyra: APRIL JUST SIGNED
WITH NEW YORK MODELS,
AND THE OWNER OF THE AGENCY
IS SO IMPRESSED WITH HER
THAT HE IS MANAGING HER
HIMSELF.
♪♪♪
Eric: YOU LOOK LIKE
A NUBIAN SPACE GODDESS.
Nolé: XIOMARA--
ABSOLUTELY GORGEOUS GIRL,
BUT SHE LOOKED LIKE
A WALRUS.
Xiomara: I KNEW I WASN'T
PERFECT WALKING IN THE DOOR.
I SO KNEW THAT.
J.: GIRL, YOU WALK
LIKE YOU ARE ON CRACK.
Xiomara:
I'M THE KIND OF PERSON
WHERE SOMEONE TELLS ME
SOMETHING,
I WILL TAKE THAT AND
CHANNEL IT INTO POSITIVE.
Betsey: XIOMARA.
ALL RIGHTY.
Tyra: THE REASON WHY SHE'S HERE
IS HER ENERGY WAS SO GREAT.
Xiomara:
I'M SO HOT!
Tyra: SHE JUST HAS
THIS NEW YORK GIRL ATTITUDE.
Xiomara: I WAS BORN
IN BROOKLYN, BUT I HAVE
THE CULTURAL EDGE OF BEING
RAISED IN NEW YORK.
I JUST THINK THAT
NEW YORK HAS A FLAVOR
AND A TRENDINESS
AND A VIBE.
Tyra:
I LOVE IT.
Andrew:
GOOD.
Tyra: XIOMARA,
THE JUDGES LOVE
YOUR PERSONALITY,
BUT ON PHOTO SHOOTS,
YOU LOSE YOUR FOCUS AND
DON'T TAKE DIRECTION WELL.
Tyra:
THANK YOU, XIOMARA.
Xiomara: I'M ABSOLUTELY
MORE CONFIDENT
SINCE BEING ON THE SHOW.
I HAVE DEFINITELY IMPROVED
A LOT PHYSICALLY,
EMOTIONALLY, MENTALLY.
I'VE HAD TO WORK HARD
FOR EVERYTHING
THAT I HAVE IN LIFE.
I'M VERY DETERMINED.
NOTHING'S EVER
JUST HANDED TO ME.
I'M A NIGHTCLUB BARTENDER.
THAT'S THE BEST WAY TO WORK
TWO NIGHTS A WEEK,
MAKE A GRAND, WHERE YOU
HAVE MONDAY THROUGH FRIDAY
TO GO ON WHATEVER CASTINGS
OR GO-SEES YOU HAVE TO GO ON.
I'M GOING TO SEE
MY PERSONAL MANAGER,
WHO I'M GONNA SIGN WITH
TODAY OVER AT T.T.A.
HER JOB IS BASICALLY
TO CREATE SUPERSTARS
AS SHE'S DONE IN THE PAST.
Marianne: FIRST OF ALL,
MY PLAN FOR YOU
IS TO MAKE YOU A STAR.
YOU LISTEN TO EVERYTHING
THAT I'VE TOLD YOU TO DO.
I MEAN, YOUR HAIR-- I WANT IT
A LITTLE FULLER HERE.
- Xiomara: THAT.
- Marianne: A LITTLE SOFTER.
Xiomara:
MM-HMM. YEAH.
Marianne: YOU ARE GOING TO BE
MY TOP GIRL.
Xiomara: I GOT SIGNED
EXCLUSIVELY TO BOSS MODELS.
I'M JUST REALLY EXCITED.
James: I WAS AWARE OF HER
FROM THE SHOW,
AND SHE CAME IN
ONE DAY FOR OUR OPEN CALL.
I JUST SAW HER RIGHT AWAY
'CAUSE I KNEW
SHE WAS VERY TALL,
STRIKING, BEAUTIFUL.
- YOU OKAY?
- Xiomara: I'M OKAY.
YEAH, I'M... (laughing)
THE THING THAT HAS
CHANGED ME THE MOST
FROM BEING ON THE SHOW IS
WALKING INTO THE ROOM
WITH THE CONFIDENCE OF
SAYING, "YOU KNOW WHAT?
I CAN OWN THIS ROOM.
I DESERVE TO BE HERE."
RIGHT NOW IS
THE REAL COMPETITION.
RIGHT NOW--RIGHT NOW.
WHO'S MAKING MOVES? WHO'S NOT?
WHO'S BOOKING WORK?
WHO'S NOT?
THAT'S ALL.
Tyra: XIOMARA
HAS HAD REQUESTS
FROM THREE MAJOR
COSMETIC LINES,
AND SHE JUST DID A SPREAD
FOR "FHM" MAGAZINE.
♪♪♪
Heather: I JUST LIKE
TO HAVE FUN.
I'M A GIRL.
GIRLS LIKE TO HAVE FUN.
(laughing)
I LIKE DOING
SPONTANEOUS THINGS.
I'M A VERY PEOPLE PERSON,
AND I'M VERY TALKATIVE,
SO THAT'S THE ONLY THING
THAT BOTHERED ME,
IS THAT I DID FEEL
A LITTLE BIT ALONE IN THE HOUSE.
I'M ONLY 18 YEARS OLD, AND I'VE
NEVER BEEN AWAY FROM HOME.
CATIE SEEMS TO UNDERSTAND ME,
AND IT MAKES ME HAPPY
THAT SOMEONE ELSE
FEELS THE SAME WAY I DO.
THAT I'M NOT ALONE
IN THIS HOUSE.
Tyra: SOMETIMES WE THINK
YOU MAY LOOK A LITTLE TOO TEEN.
Eric: WHEN I LOOK AT HER HERE,
I SEE NICKELODEON.
Jay: I HAD TO FIGHT
WITH HEATHER ON THE SHOOT
JUST TO GET
HER FACIAL EXPRESSION
TO LOOK SOMEWHAT
LIKE A MODEL.
CLOSE YOUR MOUTH.
HEATHER'S OUT.
Heather:
I AM JUST SHOCKED.
I KNOW THAT I'M PRETTIER
THAN A LOT OF THOSE GIRLS
STANDING UP THERE.
SO I'M GOING
TO CONTINUE TRYING,
AND I'M NOT GONNA
LET THIS DRAG ME DOWN.
THIS HAS CHANGED MY LIFE BY ALL
THE DOORS OPENING FOR ME.
Woman: HERE AT UPN,
WE OVERSEE THE CASTING
OF ALL OF OUR
TELEVISION SERIES.
I'D LOVE FOR YOU TO TAKE
A LOOK AT OUR SCRIPT,
READ IT AND
GIVE IT YOUR BEST SHOT.
Heather: I WANTED
TO BAKE A CAKE,
BUT I CAN'T FIND MY NONSTICK
SUNFLOWER CAKE PAN.
Woman:
IT'S JUST GREAT.
I MEAN, IF YOU TAKE THE CLASSES
AND YOU PURSUE IT,
YOU REALLY HAVE
A GOOD SHOT AT IT.
Heather: I HOPE TO JUST
KEEP MODELING.
HOPEFULLY, GET ANYTHING
IN ACTING, MODELING.
I WANT IT ALL.
DREAMS DO COME TRUE.
COMING UP, HOT TIMES WITH
CAMILLE.
MY CRAZY GIRLFRIENDS. WHEN WE GO
TO THE CLUB, IT'S ALWAYS VIP
ACCESS.
AND A WINNER'S DREAM, COMES
TRUE.
I'M PART OF LIKE, THE FASHION
OLMYPICS.
Tyra: BELIEVE IT OR NOT,
CAMILLE WAS SUPER SWEET
ON HER AUDITION.
SHE WAS DRESSED
A LITTLE FLASHY.
SHE HAD ON, LIKE,
A GOLD LAMé SKIRT,
BUT SHE WAS JUST REALLY
NORMAL, SWEET--
ACTUALLY, A LITTLE BIT
TOO NORMAL AND SWEET.
SO I WAS REALLY SHOCKED
THAT SHE TURNED OUT TO BE
THE GIRL
THAT EVERYONE HATED.
♪♪♪
Camille: WHAT'S GONNA
DIFFERENTIATE ME
FROM ALL THOSE OTHER GIRLS
IS THE FACT
THAT I CAN DO IT BETTER.
Tasha:
SHE'S CLUELESS.
Camille: IT WAS A HIGHLY
STRESSFUL ENVIRONMENT.
TRUST ME, IF I'VE GOT
SOMETHING TO SAY TO YOU--
- Yoanna: I DON'T TRUST YOU.
- Sara: WHOO!
Camille: THE WHOLE EXPERIENCE
HAS BEEN AN INTERESTING ONE.
EVERY SINGLE EMOTION
THAT YOU CAN POSSIBLY THINK
WOULD RUN THROUGH YOUR SYSTEM
HAPPENED ON THAT SHOW.
THE PERSON THAT I CAN SAY
THAT I GOT ALONG THE LEAST WITH
HAS TO BE... YOANNA.
Yoanna: WAIT. JUST--
I'M NOT FINISHED! JUST WAIT.
Camille: I HONESTLY THINK
TO THIS DAY THERE IS SOMETHING
ABOUT MY PERSONALITY,
SOMETHING ABOUT
MY CONFIDENCE LEVEL
THAT I THINK THAT
YOANNA SAW IN ME,
AND SHE WISHED THAT
SHE POSSESSED HERSELF.
Yoanna: CAMILLE-- SHE'S
SUCKING ALL OF OUR ENERGY OUT,
AND SHE IS SO MANIPULATIVE
AND SO SNEAKY ABOUT IT.
Camille: I CAN HELP YOU
GUYS OUT IN SOME WAYS.
Sara: I CAN TELL THAT
CAMILLE'S GONNA BE SOMEBODY
THAT'S GONNA CAUSE
A LOT OF PROBLEMS.
I THINK SHE JUST REALLY BELIEVES
THAT SHE'S THE... THE STUFF.
Jay: YOU HAVE
15 MINUTES TO ACHIEVE
A GLAMOROUS SMOKY EYE.
GO.
- Women: (shouting)
- Yoanna: AAH!
SURPRISE, SURPRISE.
CRUELLA DE VIL
STEALS THE MIRROR.
Xiomara: CAMILLE HAS
A HUGE ASS.
HER BUTT IS TAKING UP
THE WHOLE COUNTER SPACE.
Jenascia: OH, MY GOD.
I WAS SO PISSED OFF.
LIKE, SERIOUSLY, I JUST
WANTED TO STOP AND SCREAM.
Camille: IT'S A COMPETITION,
NOT A SORORITY.
Mercedes:
CAMILLE IS MANIPULATIVE.
Yoanna: CAMILLE--IT'S LIKE,
DRAMA, DRAMA, DRAMA, DRAMA.
Eric: GROUND CONTROL
TO CAMILLE.
Janice: OKAY,
IF YOU COULD BE A JUDGE
AND ELIMINATE ANYONE,
WHO WOULD IT BE?
Camille: OOH,
THAT'S A HARD QUESTION.
- Sara: IT'D BE CAMILLE.
- April: CAMILLE.
- Xiomara: CAMILLE.
- Yoanna: CAMILLE!
Camille:
OH... MY... GOD.
Michael: (Italian accent)
OKAY, SHE WANTS TO KNOW
WHY YOU WALK LIKE THIS.
Camille:
THIS IS MY SIGNATURE WALK,
AND THIS IS WHAT'S GOING
TO MAKE ME FAMOUS.
ACTUALLY, I'M HERE BECAUSE
I GOT CHOSEN OUT OF 6,000 GIRLS.
Janice: CAMILLE,
WHAT WERE YOU THINKING?
Nigel: TIME AND TIME AGAIN,
WE'VE TALKED TO YOU
ABOUT ATTITUDE.
Tyra: THE PHOTOGRAPHER
SAID CAMILLE WAS BY FAR
HIS LEAST FAVORITE GIRL.
Michael: TRY TO WORK
ON HUMILITY A LITTLE BIT.
Tyra: I DON'T THINK
THIS IS THE PLACE FOR HER--
THIS COMPETITION.
I THINK SHE NEEDS TO BE
SOMEWHERE TELLING PEOPLE
WHAT TO DO RATHER THAN
TAKING ADVICE.
Camille: I CAN'T REALLY
GO PLACES LIKE I USED TO
WITHOUT PEOPLE RECOGNIZING ME
AND STOPPING ME
TO ASK ME, LIKE,
A MILLION AND ONE QUESTIONS.
Camille: YOU WANT ME
TO AUTOGRAPH THIS FOR YOU?
- Woman: YES.
- Camille: REALLY? OH!
HOWARD UNIVERSITY IS A VERY
PRESTIGIOUS SCHOOL.
IT'S OFTENTIMES REFERRED
TO AS THE "BLACK HARVARD."
YOU KNOW, IT'S ALL ABOUT
LOOKING GOOD.
HOWARD IS DEFINITELY
A FASHION SCHOOL.
IT'S FRIDAY NIGHT,
AND WE ARE HERE TO PARTY.
WE'RE IN WASHINGTON, D.C.
WE'RE GONNA HIT UP
ALL THE FABULOUS CLUBS.
WE CAN'T GO OUT
LOOKING LIKE A BUM.
Woman: EVEN THOUGH SHE ISN'T
AMERICA'S TOP MODEL,
SHE'S OUR TOP MODEL.
SHE'S THE DIVA.
Camille: MY CRAZY
GIRLFRIENDS--
WHEN WE GO TO THE CLUB,
WE ALL GET TOGETHER.
WE ALL GET DRESSED UP.
UM, IT'S ALWAYS
V.I.P. ACCESS,
AND SO THAT'S
JUST TYPICAL FOR US.
AS FAR AS THE BODYGUARDS
ARE CONCERNED,
BECAUSE OF
MY POPULARITY NOW,
I HAVE TO JUST LOOK OUT FOR
MY OWN SAFETY, YOU KNOW?
SO, UM, THAT'S THAT.
HEY, GUYS,
WELCOME TO MAMARONECK,
MY HOMETOWN WHERE I GREW UP.
COME ON. LET'S GO.
MOM!
THIS IS MY MOTHER,
MISS LORNA McDONALD.
Lorna: THIS IS MY BABY,
MY ONE AND ONLY.
SPOILED TO THE HILT.
Camille:
I'M NOT SPOILED, MA.
Lorna: YOU KNOW,
WE DID OUR BEST.
HER DAD AND MYSELF
DID OUR BEST
TO RAISE HER IN
THE BEST WAY WE KNEW HOW,
AND REALLY, I'M VERY
PROUD OF HER.
I THINK YOU'RE JUST
MUCH MORE DETERMINED.
MAYBE I'M JUST NOTICING IT.
Camille: I MEAN, I WENT
ON NATIONAL TELEVISION
AND TOLD PEOPLE
THAT MY SIGNATURE WALK
WAS GONNA MAKE ME FAMOUS.
YOU'RE NOT GONNA GET
THE FULL EFFECT
'CAUSE I DON'T
HAVE ON HEELS HERE.
Camille: I'M REALLY NOT
A BITCH.
I'M SWEET,
I'M KIND, I'M LOVING.
I JUST WANT EVERYONE OUT THERE
TO KNOW THAT I'M SERIOUS
AND I'M DETERMINED
AND I HAVE CONFIDENCE.
I DON'T EVER WANT ANYONE
TO MIX UP CONFIDENCE
FOR ARROGANCE.
TRUST ME,
YOU WILL SEE ME AGAIN.
Camille: CIAO.
Tyra: I THINK
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"
HAS, YOU KNOW, CREATED
NEW LIVES FOR THESE WOMEN.
I MEAN, SHANDI
WAS A WALGREENS CLERK,
AND NOW SHE'S GONNA BE
A FASHION MODEL.
UM, YOANNA WAS A BABYSITTER,
AND NOW SHE'S AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL.
♪♪♪
Tyra: AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL IS...
YOANNA.
Jay: YOANNA'S
ABSOLUTELY BEAUTIFUL.
Nigel: I THINK YOANNA'S
AMAZING.
Janice: YOU HAVE A CLASSIC
FACE MADE FOR BEAUTY.
Yoanna: AAH!
IT'S NOT REAL.
IT'S 7 IN THE MORNING.
I HAVE AN ENTOURAGE
FOLLOWING ME NOW,
AND I'M JUST A LITTLE
UNCOMFORTABLE WITH THE IDEA.
I'M HERE WITH MY MOM,
AND WE'RE OFF TO GO
TO OUR FIRST MORNING SHOW--
CBS MORNING.
Harry: ON TUESDAY NIGHT,
MILLIONS TUNED IN
TO WATCH YOANNA HOUSE
BECOME AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
WHAT HAS THIS BEEN LIKE
NOW FOR WHAT,
THE 24, 36 HOURS
OR WHATEVER IT IS?
Yoanna: IT'S ALL JUST
GOING REALLY FAST.
AFTER THAT,
WE TREK ON OVER
WITH JUST A FEW MINUTES
TO SPARE,
AND WE GO
TO "REGIS AND KELLY LIVE."
IT WAS REALLY COOL.
THE AUDIENCE IS,
LIKE, REALLY--
LIKE JUST REALLY ENJOYABLE,
AND THEY JUST MADE
THE WHOLE EXPERIENCE
EVEN MORE ENJOYABLE.
Tyra:
WE HAVE SOME PRIZES--
A COSMETICS CAMPAIGN
WITH SEPHORA.
Yoanna: I CAN'T WAIT TO GET
A FREE SHOPPING SPREE
AT SEPHORA.
GOING INTO SEPHORA
WAS KIND OF LIKE, UH,
CHARLIE GOING INTO
THE WILLIE WONKA FACTORY.
UM, THERE'S, LIKE,
ALL THESE PRODUCTS,
AND THEN THEY SAY, "OKAY,
PICK AND CHOOSE,"
AND I THOUGHT FOR
A MINUTE, "ARE YOU INSANE?"
Tyra: YOU WILL ALSO HAVE
A SPREAD IN "JANE" MAGAZINE.
Yoanna: I GO UP TO MEET WITH
ERIC FROM "JANE" MAGAZINE,
AND HE'S
LAYING OUT THE THEMES
FOR WHAT THE PHOTO SHOOT'S
GOING TO BE.
I'M LIKE, "WHAT IS GOING ON
WITH MY LIFE TODAY?"
Tyra: AMONG THE PRIZES
THAT THE WINNER WILL RECEIVE
IS A CONTRACT WITH IMG,
WHICH IS THE NUMBER ONE
MODELING MANAGEMENT FIRM
IN THE WORLD.
Yoanna:
TODAY'S THE BIG DAY.
I FINALLY GET TO MEET WITH IMG
FOR THE FIRST TIME.
- HI.
- Man: HOW ARE YOU?
- CONGRATULATIONS.
- Yoanna: THANK YOU.
Man: HOW WAS THIS MORNING,
BY THE WAY?
Yoanna:
OH, HECTIC AND FUN.
Man: SO I HOPE YOU'RE NOT
GONNA BE NOT TOO TIRED.
Yoanna: I'M FINE.
Man: WE'VE GOT
A BIG, BIG WEEK.
Yoanna: THEY'RE GONNA
TELL ME MY ITINERARY
AND MAP OUT WHAT'S COMING IN
THE NEXT FEW WEEKS
AND HOPEFULLY
WITH MY CAREER,
SO THIS IS THE BEST PART
OF THE WHOLE EXPERIENCE.
Man: ON MONDAY,
NANCY'S GONNA ACCOMPANY YOU,
AND YOU'RE GONNA
GO OUT TO L.A.
Yoanna:
OH, YEAH.
(applause)
Ryan: THE HIT UPN SHOW,
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"
RECENTLY CROWNED ITS WINNER,
AND SHE IS RIGHT HERE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN,
A BABYSITTER TURNED SUPERMODEL--
YOANNA HOUSE.
COME ON OUT.
(cheers and applause)
Yoanna: FROM THERE,
THEY HAD SAID,
"WELL, YOU'RE GONNA BE
DOING L.A. FASHION WEEK."
Yoanna: IT'S MAYHEM!
IT'S SO COOL, THOUGH.
WE'RE GETTING READY TO DO
THE CUSTO BARCELONA SHOW,
AND WE'VE JUST
REACHED HAIR AND MAKEUP.
IT'S INSANE. IT'S LIKE
A DREAM COME TRUE.
THE BEST PART,
I THINK WAS, YOU KNOW,
GETTING TO DO THE SHOWS.
IT IS INSANE, AND THERE I AM
WITH THE GIRLS
THAT ARE REALLY
NOTED FOR DOING THIS,
AND IN A WAY, IT WAS JUST
KIND OF LIKE, "OH, MY GOD.
I'M PART OF, LIKE,
THE FASHION OLYMPICS."
THAT'S WHAT IT WAS LIKE.
WELL, IT'S MY
24TH BIRTHDAY TODAY,
AND I'M SO EXCITED
TO BE HOME.
Girl: BRAVA!
Yoanna: I JUST GET TO BE
WITH MY LITTLE SISTER, MY MOM,
MY DAD, MY BROTHER,
AND IT'S THE BEST GIFT.
WELL, I GREW UP
IN JACKSONVILLE, FLORIDA,
IN THIS GREAT LITTLE AREA
CALLED MANDARIN.
BEFORE THE SHOW, I GUESS
YOU COULD SAY I WAS THE GIRL
THAT WAS JUST VERY MUCH
THE BOHEMIAN.
I WAS THE BABYSITTER
EXTRAORDINAIRE.
I HAD A SET FAMILY
THAT I WORKED WITH
FOR ALMOST FOUR YEARS.
I'D SAY AS OF NOW,
EVEN POST-SHOW,
I LOST A TOTAL
OF 60 POUNDS,
WHICH TOOK ABOUT A TWO
AND A HALF-YEAR PROCESS.
REALLY, THE DRIVING FORCE WAS ME
WANTING TO GET INTO FASHION.
Yoanna's mom: THEY START
FROM KINDERGARTEN
THROUGH THE EIGHTH GRADE.
AND THIS WHEN SHE START
THINKING TO LOSING WEIGHT.
Yoanna:
I ALWAYS HAD, LIKE,
THE FASHIONISTA
INSIDE ME ALWAYS,
AND I THINK IT'S ALWAYS
GOING TO BE THERE.
PEOPLE--MAYBE I THINK SINCE
THE WEIGHT HAS COME OFF,
HAVE MAYBE PAID
MORE ATTENTION.
WE'RE HERE AT THE YOGA DEN
STUDIO IN MY HOMETOWN,
AND I'M HERE
WITH MY LITTLE SISTER.
WE'RE ABOUT TO GO INSIDE
TO DO OUR DAILY ROUTINE
OF WORKING OUT.
WELL, AS FAR AS, LIKE,
A TRANSFORMATION I TOOK
WHERE I WANTED TO TONE
AND LENGTHEN,
STRENGTHEN MY BODY,
IT DID HAPPEN HERE.
(Southern accent)
♪ I NEVER WAS A CHEERLEADER ♪♪
NEVER MADE HOMECOMIN'
OR PROM QUEEN, NOTHIN'.
(normal voice)
NOT ONLY DID I WIN,
BUT I WON SOMETHING THAT
I HAD WANTED, LIKE,
SINCE I WAS SO YOUNG
AND FOR A LONG TIME.
IF YOU BELIEVE IN YOURSELF,
YOU REALLY CAN ACHIEVE,
YOU KNOW, WHAT YOU
REALLY WANT OUT OF LIFE.
I'M JUST SO OVERWHELMED
WITH THIS WHOLE EXPERIENCE,
AND I CAN'T WAIT
TO GET TO WORK.
Tyra: YOU THINK YOU HAVE
WHAT IT TAKES TO BE
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL?
GO TO upn.com,
DOWNLOAD THAT APPLICATION,
SEND IN THAT 3-MINUTE TAPE.
DO EVERYTHING THAT APPLICATION
SAYS THAT YOU SHOULD DO,
AND MAYBE YOU'LL BE HANGING OUT
WITH ME IN THE NYC.
SEE YOU.
♪♪♪